Hello Freak bitches.
This is one of the things that I think Western civilization has contributed so
brilliantly to,
to the expansion of knowledge and the world is,
well,
what's the,
what's the cure for the inadequacies of the group?
While you might say it's the perfect state.
So one of the ways I'm going to do a series of lectures on the Bible starting
May 16th and for reasons that I outlined to some degree when I was talking about
genesis a little bit earlier,
but in the old testament for example,
the Israelites are always trying to make their peace with God.
So they're trying to live in the world without getting wall up to constantly buy
natural events.
And by you know,
invading forces in which they attribute to God's will.
Yes,
yes.
Whatever's beyond their understanding,
in some sense they're more sophisticated than merely this,
but the,
whatever's beyond their understanding.
But they're kind of conceptualizing being as such and trying to figure out how
to deal with it.
And one of the hypothesis they come up with is something like,
well,
you can bargain with it.
And the thing is you can,
that's one of the things that's so cool and partly the reason you can bargain
with reality is because the reality that you encounter as you move forward in
time is partly the world,
but partly the abstract social system.
And so you can bargain with the future abstract social system all the time.
You do that every time you make a promise,
you do it every time you sacrifice one thing for another,
you know,
so you,
you forego a impulsive temptation and that gives you a moral claim that you can
redeem in the future.
That happens,
all that.
That's what money is for God's sake.
And you know,
we discovered the future at some point,
as I said,
we were chimpanzees at one point we discovered the future,
then we discovered that you could bargain with the future as if it was a person.
That's amazing.
It's amazing.
And that's partly where the idea of God as a personality came from.
I should flip that.
That idea that you could bargain with the future came out of the idea that God
was a personality because the God as a personality idea came first.
But it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a developmental stage on the way to even being able to say the future.
You know,
we,
we have no idea how they said like a 6 million year path from chimpanzee to,
to self aware human being,
you know,
and we don't,
we have no idea where these unbelievably sophisticated ideas that we have come
from.
Like the idea of sacrifice.
Do you know how much blood was spilled before human beings were able to
sacrifice abstractly instead of killing something?
We had to act out.
God enjoys you killing something because he's happy with the blood.
We had to act that out for God.
Who knows?
20,000 years,
a hundred thousand years before we got anywhere near the idea that you could do
that abstractly.
So when I look at these old stories,
I look at them like an evolutionary biologist.
Now.
I'm not trying to reduce them in any way because what we don't understand about
evolution that could make a very thick book,
and there's other strange things about religious phenomenology that we don't
have a clue about.
You know,
like the fact that the drugs often called entheogens,
psychedelics can reliably produce mystical experiences.
No one has any idea what to make of that.
You can just discount it.
It's like,
yeah,
well you know they're drugs.
Yeah,
sure.
People been using the things for who knows,
50,000 years,
150,000 years.
They might be the source of all our religious ideas.
I don't,
I'm not saying that they are,
but they could well be and so why do we have a capacity for mystical experience?
Who knows it?
It's it.
It's associated with the sense of awe.
It's associated with the same feeling that you get when you listen to
particularly dramatic music or when a or when something moves you deeply and you
know the hair on the back of your neck stands up.
You know what that is?
That's pilot erection.
That's the same thing that happens to a cat when it looks at a particularly big
dog.
It's all you feel that when there's a swell of music,
aw,
you're the hair stands up on the back of your neck.
It's like you pop up just like a cat except like a bald cat.
So what do you make of this idea that,
well not the idea,
but they're the reality that these entheogens closely mimic human
neurochemistry.
No.
What they do,
there's absolutely no doubt about that body.
What do you think the reason for that is?
Well,
part of the reason is,
is that we share an evolutionary pathway with all these things that we eat,
you know,
plants and fungi and you know,
look,
we're,
we're linked evolutionarily to every form of life on the planet,
you know,
and,
and like Serotonin in lobsters and it has the same effect on lobsters as it does
on human beings.
So if you up their serotonin levels artificially,
the lobster gets,
stands up more erect and,
and stronger and as much more willing to fight.
And if you decrease the serotonin in the lobsters nervous system,
then it gets all depressed and runs away and hides.
Think,
think about that.
I mean,
we,
we split off from lobsters about 350 million years ago and they still live in
dominance hierarchies.
That's how old the dominance hierarchy is.
There's plant that's older than trees.
It's older than flowers.
It's permanent,
right?
We've evolved for the hierarchy and the spirit of the hierarchy.
That's,
that's the Old Testament God,
that's at least part of it,
the spirit of the hierarchy.
So these things are,
while they're mind boggling to me,
which is partly why I'm investigating them,
but all of our wiring is conditional on that.
So,
and I mean,
women use the dominance hierarchy to select mates.
So it's so strange because you know,
people think of evolution from a natural selection perspective almost always,
but sexual selection plays a huge role.
So here are all a layout,
something wild for you.
Okay.
So we know that you have twice as many female ancestors as male ancestors.
Now people have a hard time with that.
But you could imagine that,
um,
roughly speaking,
that would happen if every single woman had one baby and only every second man
fathered a child.
So for man,
it would be you either have two kids,
they're zero.
Well,
that's basically what it is on average across time.
If you're a man,
you have two children,
maybe with two different women or zero.
If you're a woman,
everyone has one.
That's how it averages out.
So there's more disparity of success among men.
And that's very common in the animal kingdom by the way.
Now the question is how do women select their mate?
Now,
unlike female chimps,
female humans are choosy maters.
Female chimps will mate with any chimp.
They go into heat,
they'll mate with any chimp.
The dominant males are more likely to meet with them.
But that's because they chase away the subordinate.
It's not because the females exercise choice,
human females exercise choice.
And that's one of the things that differentiated us from chimpanzees.
But how do they do it?
Well,
they look at the male dominance hierarchy and that's where the men are
competing.
Now you could say they're competing for power,
but that's pretty corrupt way of looking at it.
Like they're competing for,
let's say,
influence.
They're competing for leadership.
And so in some sense the people at the top of the hierarchy,
if they're men are elected by the other band.
Now I know there was brutes and there's predators and all of that,
but I'm talking on average across time.
It's like the men organize themselves and there are influential men that rise to
the top and the women take them.
Now he think about that.
What that means is that over the millions of years that a dominance hierarchy
with those properties existed.
So let's say since we split from chimps,
let's say that 6 million years,
that means that the male dominance hierarchy is the environment that pushes the
mating mail to the top.
So that means the mail that's most likely to take precedence in the dorm and the
male dominance hierarchy is the one most likely to leave a genetic contribution.
So that means that the male dominance hierarchies,
a selection mechanism mediated by the female.
So what that means is that as we've moved forward through 6 million years of
time,
men have become more and more well adapted,
not only to the presence of the male dominance hierarchy,
but two,
the ability to move up it.
And that's the central spirit.
You could say in some sense,
that's the central spirit of the individual.
The individual is the thing that can move up.
Dominance,
hierarchies.
It's the thing that's at the top.
It's the eye at the top of the pyramid and it's been selected for.
And then what's happened is that we've watched.
So we get better and better and better for biological reasons,
culturally mediated at figuring out how to climb across a set of dominance
hierarchy so we can leave a genetic contribution.
That's what's happened to human beings.
Now imagine that that's happened for 6 million years.
So now imagine that we started to watch that because we're curious creatures.
We're always trying to figure out who we are.
And then as we watched that,
we started to tell stories about what the people who could climb the hierarchies
were like those were heroes.
That's where Harold mythology came from.
And the biggest hero is the person will go out and kill the snake.
Well unsurprisingly,
because that was a big hero man,
and maybe when we are living in trees that was a hero.
So the big hero is the person who goes out,
slays the dragon,
gets the gold,
brings it back to the community and distributes it.
He's also the person most likely to go up the dominant Turkey.
He's the person most likely to find the virgin,
right?
Cause it's a virgin that you free from the Dragon,
then you get to claim her.
Right?
And so the dominance hierarchy is a mechanism that selects heroes and then
breeds them.
And so then we watched that for 6 million years.
We start to understand what it means to be the hero.
We start to tell stories about that.
And so then not only are we genetically aiming at that with the dominant Turk is
a selection mechanism mediated by female choice.
But our stories are trying to push us in that direction.
And so then we say,
well look,
that person's admirable.
Tell a story about him and we say this person is admirable.
Tell a story about him and this person is admirable.
And at the same time we talk about the people who aren't admirable.
And then we start having admirable and non admirable as categories.
And out of that you get something like good and evil and then you can start to
imagine the perfect person that would be not only,
so it would be you take 10 admirable people and you pull out someone who's metta
admirable.
And that's a hero that becomes a religious figure across time.
That becomes a savior,
a messiah across time as we conceptualize what the ideal person is
and we didn't in the West,
here's how we figured it out.
We said the ideal person,
the ideal man is the person who tells the truth.
And what that means is that's the best way of climbing up any possible dominance
hierarchy in a way that's most stable and most lasting.
That's,
that's the conclusion of western culture.
So in a sense,
psychologically,
when you're talking about postmodernists and their rejection of these classic
male structures are,
what they doing is realizing that they're not going to compete in the,
the classic as stated male hierarchy.
So they're creating their own version of it.
Sure.
That's the creative element.
While we,
we,
we asked earlier,
what's the motivation of these pathological guys who are out there,
like bolstering up the feminists.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they don't compete any other way.
They don't compete.
They figured out how to compete.
They compete as allies,
let's say.
Very sneaky.
Wow.
Yeah.
Niki.